>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hello everyone, thanks for coming
to the Library of Congress today.
My name is [laughter], my name
is a very amplified Rob Casper.
Can you hear me in the back?
Okay, I'm Rob Casper,
I'm Head of the Poetry
and Literature Center here at the
Library of Congress and I want
to welcome you to our National
Poetry Month conversations
with African Poets
and Writers Program,
featuring Caine Prize
Winne Lidudumalingani.
We're thrilled to have him here,
we're thrilled to have you here,
we're thrilled to celebrate
the Caine Prize.
I want to give a special
thanks to Lizzy Attree,
the Director of Caine Prize
for helping make this possible.
I could not be more delighted with
this series and with the partners
that we work with and I'm going
to introduce one of them right now
but before I do so, let me just
ask you to turn off your cellphones
and electronic devices,
anything you might have
that would interfere
with this event.
Second, they'll be a
Q&A session afterwards.
Please note that this program is
being recorded and by participating
in the Q&A session,
you give us permission
for future use of the recording.
This series started really out
of a partnership with the African
and Middle Eastern division
and its Chief, Mary-Jane Deeb
and she's been an inspiration to
all of us that have gotten a chance
to work with her and I'm
delighted that we have continued it
and deepened our partnership and
she'll talk a little bit more
about new partnerships going forward
but it's a tremendous series,
I'm very proud to have done it and
I'm very thankful to Mary-Jane Deeb
for helping make it possible so
please welcome Mary-Jane Deeb.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, well welcome, welcome to
the African Middle East Division,
I mean it's very exciting today to
start 2017, with our Conversations
With African Poets and Writers.
And as Rob Casper said,
this is a series
that has become iconic
if I may say so.
It is known across the globe,
people are very much aware
of the great speakers that we
have brought to the library.
Let me say a few words, the Poetry
and Literature Center has been
a fantastic partner with us
and so has been two other
institutions, the African Society
of the National Summit on Africa
has been there from day one
and day one goes back to
a major event that we did
with the great poet Achebe,
writer and poet Achebe.
We did this program almost a decade
ago and we had started it also
with another partner who
is coming back on board
and that is Howard University.
Howard University had organized
a major symposium on Achebe
and we always thought Howard
University should be a partner
and low and behold, today I want to
announce that Professor Mbye Cham,
representing Howard University,
has agreed to be a partner
so now we have Library of
Congress two divisions,
Poetry and Literature Center
and African Middle East Division
and the African Society at Howard
University are cosponsoring our
series on, Conversations With
African Poets and Writers.
The Poetry Center has been a
fantastic partner and has brought
in a number of award
winning writers.
The African section, all
four of the specialists
in the African section have
been fantastic representatives
of this division in bringing and
informing us about writers and poets
for our writing, not
only the established ones
but the new ones like the one today.
And now to introduce the Caine
Prize Winner Lidudumalingani,
we have the President
of the African Society
who will be doing the introduction
so here we have Patricia Baine.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning or good afternoon.
So we're here, welcome
this afternoon.
I'm proud to introduce
Lidudumalingani,
who won the 2016 Caine
Prize for African Writing,
described as Africa's
leading literary award
for his short story entitled,
Memories we Lost, that was published
in The Incredible Journey,
Stories That Move You.
Memories we Lost tells the
emotionally charged story of a girl
who acts as a protector
of her sister,
whose serious mental health
problems caused consternation
in South African village.
Her situation deteriorates as he
care is entrusted to [inaudible],
a local man who employs
traditional techniques
to get rid of people's demons.
Lidudumalingani is a writer, he's
a filmmaker, and a photographer
and I remember reading someplace
that he says that he
writes visually.
I guess he will explain to us what
that means, he thinks visually.
I think the photography
overtakes all other aspects.
This is a very short synapsis of
the writer's bio which, by no means,
is a reflection of
the accomplishments
and the amazing things
that he has done.
He was born in the Eastern
Cape Province of South Africa.
He has published short
stories, nonfiction,
and criticisms in various
publications.
His films have been screened at
a number of films and festivals.
This is the part I like,
he is called the cool kid
of South African literature
currently [laughter]
so we welcome him to
the Conversations
With African Poets and Writers.
I am now going to ask Laverne Page,
no, to start the conversation.
All right, not [laughter].
I will ask Mr. Lidudumalingani
himself,
please clap for him, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Greetings.
Firstly, thank you everyone
for being here and thank you
for all the partners
for bringing me here.
I've been in DC since Monday night.
It's been interesting [laughter].
I'm going to read from page 76, and
then I think I'm supposed to read
for plus/minus 10 minutes or
to stop maybe when I'm tired.
>> We sat there and
watched the day go by.
We didn't even attempt
to say a word.
I realized then that she
and I needed no words.
In the afternoon that
day, it began to rain.
I dragged her out of the house.
We jumped in the rain,
begging it to pour on us
so we could be tall,
big, strong and bold.
In that moment, my sister returned.
She smiled and laughed.
That day we began to form
new childhood memories,
filling the void left by the
one that had been wiped out.
We lay on the ground,
stretched out our arms and legs,
rain falling on our faces and felt
free but my mother had seen us laugh
and jump, and thought that this
thing was going to come again.
The following day, the entire
village gathered outside
of our house for yet another
[inaudible] to cure my sister.
She had been through
all these rituals
and [inaudible] and
nothing had changed.
Each time, [inaudible] promised that
she would be healed within days.
There was once, at least
according to the elders,
a glimpse of the [inaudible]
healing, the [inaudible]
that had been put in the [inaudible]
for the ancestors to take at night
in one of the many rituals were
not there by morning leading them
to believe that the
ancestors had healed her.
It was not long after that,
that this thing again proving
that the [inaudible] had simply been
stolen by thieves, that it returned.
The day of the ritual I remember
how the clouds moved across the sky
in a hurry and how thick fog hung
onto the grass, the mountains,
the riverbanks and forest
as if to announce death.
It hung so low that people
appeared to be floating
with their legs cut
off below their knees.
The women's chatter and songs
reached us long before the crowd
was visible.
It appeared as if the
fog had swallowed them
and that the women would
never come into sight.
All the same, they did.
They [inaudible] and chanted
song as they approached our home.
Men came in silence, arms folded
behind their back carrying sticks.
A few minutes after the women
arrived, smoke escaped the fireplace
into the sky, dancing
with the moving clouds
as if the sky was their dance floor.
The children ran around and kicked
soccer balls that had been made
by stuffing papers
into plastic bags.
Everyone moved in a
chaotic choreography.
That way went an [inaudible]
woman carrying a bucket of water
on her head, this way went
a child with a tablecloth,
that way went a dog with a
bone, this way went chickens,
that way stood women
gossiping about my sister.
From our house, I could
see the crowds amplifying
as more people arrived.
I looked at my sister and
found her face as it had been
in earlier months, emotionless.
In the past few days she had given
me hope that she had returned.
Now, tears rolled down our cheeks.
I knew then that she still felt
something, that the last few days
of holding hands, laughing
and jumping
in the rain were not a dream.
The fog began to clear and
everything came into focus,
the mountains, landscape, river,
and the other villages
were there, unmoved.
An old man who had been smoking his
pipe behind the [inaudible] emptied
it and stuffed it in his pockets.
The ritual began.
Knives were drawn and the goat
was first stabbed in the stomach
to summon our ancestors from their
enclaves and then it was meat.
After some time, an old aunt
came for us, calling for us
to come out of the house.
We hugged tightly.
My sister and I wiped
each other's tears.
It was only after we had heard her
footsteps approaching our house
that we walked out, holding hands,
fingers tightly intertwined.
The only way to have torn me away
from her would have to cut us apart.
The villagers shouted insult at
the thing as it remained unknown
to them, for what felt like an
entire lifetime, while my sister
and I sat at [inaudible]
our heads bowed.
The elders kept referring
to this thing
as demons and the devil's work.
None of them knew my
sister, none of them cared.
The sun was up now, thick shadows
gathering around the house.
Even though there was no wind,
the windmill by the fields
made a creaking sound.
My mother was torn and defeated and
questioned why God gave this thing
to my sister and my father.
Secrets stay buried for so long
but one day they rise to open
like seeds breaking
free from the earth.
Nobody had ever mentioned
that my father had this thing,
that he had left one day on his
horse to see distant relatives
and had never come back, to only
be see in a way that [inaudible]
after their death in
dreams in hallucinations.
He had been seen in some village
at least twice, my mother told me.
The person who had seen
him yelled and waved
but he never bothered to look.
They were not sure
if it was my father
but they were convinced
that it had to be.
He was never buried, though
it is now 20 years later.
There was nothing to bury.
I have no memory of my father.
There was always hope that he
would return from somewhere.
Nobody knew where, nobody
cared as long as he returned.
The night of the ritual, my sister
and I slept lying the same way
and stared off in different
directions.
I woke up and she was
holding me, squeezing me,
and she had sunk her teeth into
the pillow so she would not cry.
She [inaudible] for a few minutes
and then fell asleep in my arms.
In the morning, I went
to milk the goat.
I saw two human shadows
hovering above the [inaudible].
At first, though it was unusual,
I thought nothing of it even
as they mumbled something
to each other.
In the shadows that lived inside
the [inaudible], with the smell
of manure, I saw that it was my
mother and an uncle who had come
to stay with us for the ritual.
It was as if their heads
were bound together into one,
creating a giant head, a ghost even.
I had meant to get out, but when
I heard them mention my sister,
I put the jug of milk
down and crouched,
leaning on the goat
so it did not move.
My father [inaudible],
the man who had moved
in with my mother were making
plans to take my sister away.
The medication and the ritual
did not work, my mother said.
The way she saw it, my sister
needed to see [inaudible].
This thing is going to
come back, she said.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay thank you very
much, is your mic on?
>> One two, one two, yeah it is.
>> So now you're going to
hear from the cool kid.
>> I'm not sure where that
comes from [laughter].
It's definitely not true.
>> Well, I was going to say
now you're going to hear
from the cool kid and the
grandmom [laughter], labels.
Thank you so much for reading that
passage from Memories we Lost,
which focuses on mental illness.
At the end of the story, the story
ends, but at the end of the story
where do these children
go, that was my question.
Children wandering around, the
one that's attempting to help,
and then the one that's ill,
where do they go especially
when you say 20 years later in your
story, so there's something there.
>> I mean, the ending was
really motivated by two factors,
one of them was the
deadline [laughter]
and the other was also this idea
that a story is never really
finished so what I really wanted
to do because it's
also a short story
and I'm usually not really
a short story writer,
I struggled with the story so the
idea was to then write an ending
that suggested that there was
a lot more going on and by
that I didn't really suggest that
it would come from me necessarily.
I was hoping that people
would read the story
and they would perhaps take
the challenge to finish it.
>> Okay, I should point
out that I'm asking this
because although I would
normally be interested,
also there's an investigation
right now currently in South Africa
into the treatment of
mentally ill patients.
They were removed, a large
number of them were removed
from their hospitals and they
were just sent elsewhere and many
of them, or most of them
died and so it's a political
and a social issue
and it's a tragedy.
And so, since you're
writing about mental illness,
I'm wondering if this
is more material for you
for the stories that you write.
>> I mean, because I wrote the story
and I've spent about possibly close
to a year talking about mental
illness in South Africa and talking
about the story specifically I mean,
when the news of that tragedy broke
out it was heartbreaking and
then there was a thing they do
in Parliament in South Africa where
the president addresses the nation
and one of the people from the
political parties, the opposition,
asked if they could give a
moment of silence to I think
at that time it was around
125 people that had died,
and the Madam Speaker of
Parliament refused and she was like,
we are not here to mourn 125 dead
people, so it was heartbreaking
for me because at that
moment I really got to kind
of understand what it means
to have a family member whose got
mental illness and what it means
when they die that the
government doesn't care.
So because of how emotional
that was for me,
I've never really seen it as,
to put it in a very crass way,
as an opportunity for material.
It's just been really heartbreaking
that I haven't even though
about do I write more about it or
do I make images or do I make forms?
I haven't really thought about it.
>> Well, let me ask you
about the Caine Prize.
I'm curious as to whether or not
it's made a great difference to you.
I'm wondering if its contributed
to your current projects
and the audiences that you reach.
When exactly were you notified
that you had won the prize?
>> It really happens in the
right, you really don't know
until the announcement
is made but I mean,
for me the exciting
thing was finding
out that I had been short listed
because Memories Lost was
a second story of fiction
that I've ever written and more
than anything it was the idea for me
that I needed to write other things
except nonfiction and so I was,
I'll write a short story
and that's what I did.
So to have it nominated,
short listed for the Caine
Prize was amazing for me.
I was really excited and I mean,
if you get short listed you go
to London and you spend about a week
doing readings and talking to people
and it's very exciting until
the night of the announcement
and then you start thinking about
who is going to win the Caine Prize.
It was exciting to win and I've
really had an exciting year
and because, I mean I've never
really written any fiction before
this so it was exciting for
me to be immediately thrown
into a very wide reading community
which I've really appreciated
which I think for any writer
that's what's important,
that your writing is read widely
and that's what's happening
to my own writing and I'm
very grateful for that.
>> For the Caine Prize, you
don't submit your own work,
someone else submits
the work, correct?
>> Yeah so the publisher submits
the work to the Caine Prize,
yes but you can ask your
publisher to submit.
[ Laughter ]
>> You can make a suggestion.
>> Okay, okay well, can you tell us
more about your current projects?
Since you're a writer, a filmmaker,
and photographer I'm just wondering
what you have been working on
and which of these genres
do you enjoy most and in
which are you the most prolific
and if there's a certain subject
that you prefer so there are
a number of questions in one.
>> I mean, the other amazing thing
that happened to me in 2016 was
that I was given then Miles
Morland Scholarship, which allows me
to spend a year writing
my debut novel
so that's what I'm going
to be doing next month.
I'm trying to really
not do anything else.
I mean, the one thing that I've
tried to, I've been working
on a full script for the past
four years and it's been really up
and down, a lot of suggestions from
people that I've sent it to so one
of the things that I've
tried to do is to finish
that full script before I
begin work on the novel.
>> What's the subject?
>> Of the novel?
>> Of the film and
also of the novel.
>> I can talk about the film
but not really the novel.
Well I mean, it's not even a novel
at this point, it's just really,
when I was in film school I went
to film school with a photographer
from South Africa called
[inaudible], who I think most
of you might be familiar
with her work.
If any of you have met her,
you would understand the power
that she has, so a lot of the
conversations that were going
around my class when I was
in film school were about,
because a lot of violence in
South Africa happens to lesbians.
There's a very terrible
thing called corrective rape
so that's what the film was
about but more than that,
the film was really looking at
a society that allows a society
where corrective rape happens so
that's what the film was about
and this is why it's been
really difficult to write
because for me it's not just
the subject but it's important
for everything about it
to kind of fit perfectly
into both my own politics but also
for the film to go against the sort
of very problematic descriptions
or problematic conversations
that have gone on around
corrective rape.
>> What does that mean,
corrective rape?
>> I mean you know, the way to
describe it is that there's the idea
that if a bunch of men
decide to rape a lesbian,
gang rape a lesbian it's called
corrective rape because the idea is
that you cannot be a lesbian so we
will show you that you are a woman,
and this is why it's
called corrective rape
because in their mind it's the idea
that you will then become a woman
as they describe and see it.
>> Okay and you cannot
tell us about the novel
so I won't ask any more
questions about the novel.
What about short stories,
since you're doing so
well with that genre?
>> I don't know about doing well,
I wrote one short story [laughter].
>> But you won the Caine Prize.
>> There's one short
story that I'm working on.
Again, I mean, my short stories
are only sort of like my writing,
and my film work, and my
photography is always really
in a way just me being very
receptive of the community
that I live in so the short
story which I'm currently working
on which I hope to
finish before the novel is
about shack fires in South Africa.
In South Africa, there's places
called informal settlements
where people live in shacks so
these are houses made of zinc
and often what happens
is that because some
of them don't have
electricity people use candles
and what happens often is there's
usually fires and people die.
I mean, I remember one in
2011, which happened right
on New Year's Eve when people
were going out to celebrate 2011,
people were dying in their houses
and about a month ago there
was another in Cape Town again,
which happened in an interesting
place where it's called,
I mean the place is called
[inaudible] and it's in Hout Bay.
I mean, it sits right next
to the very big mansions
of rich white people in Cape Town,
so I was really interested in sort
of like, that relationship
between people who live
in these very lavish houses
and people who live in shacks
and who live in poverty and these
houses that they really try to build
and get things together
without any money
and then it gets destroyed
overnight.
The short story I'm
writing is about one family
who loses it all during that fire.
>> Oh.
>> It's a very happy
story [laughter].
>> Yes, I'm just thinking about
the social issues that concern you
and it seems wide ranging and wow.
With the films, I'm curious,
I know that there is a prolific
film industry in South Africa
so lots is happening with
literature, with film-making.
Is there a difference,
since you live in Cape Town,
is there a difference between Cape
Town and Johannesburg in terms
of let's say literary activities?
>> [Inaudible] is here, he can
maybe help me out [laughter].
Look I think, I mean Cape Town is
interesting in a way because I mean,
there's a lot going on especially
with young Black creatives
and we try to get together and do
things but the larger community is
in Johannesburg and I mean, I've
toyed with the idea of going
to Johannesburg a lot
but it hasn't happened.
There's certainly differences
and I think Johannesburg
is far more receptive
of young Black creatives both
in filmmaking and literature
and Cape Town is less so.
Cape Town is still predominantly
very white oriented both
when it comes to spaces to exhibit
your work whether it's films
or you want to read literature
so you have to really find sort
of the spaces that have
been curated for people
like you to go read your work.
And often, you find that's perhaps
the best way to read your work
to people that actually I
suppose to put it very bluntly,
won't be asking you very obvious
questions about what you're trying
to do, people understand
what you're trying to do.
>> And can you tell us something
about where you read your
work a little bit more,
those of us who may not
know that side of city life?
>> Generally, I'm just
at home the whole time.
I mean, I hear a bunch of people
reading their work and then I plan
to go but things happen
and then I don't go.
I just stay at home and read but
there's a place called Observatory,
some people can get around there,
there's different places there
to read your work but
there's also young people,
there's a thing called creative
nestling which gets people together
to read their work both in
Johannesburg and Cape Town.
>> Creative?
>> Creative nestling.
>> Nestling.
>> Yeah so that happens as well in
Cape Town but also I have a circle
of friends that I can
send my work too.
I mean, I'm in touch with
those people on email
and if I finish a short
story I send it
and if they finish
anything they send it around
and we can all read
each other's work
which I think is hugely
important in Cape Town to do.
>> Well, there's a quote attributed
to you in one of your interviews,
"I think South African people
should read more South African
and African fiction before
reading anything else.
There seems to be a growing list of
new Black writers being published
at the moment and this
is encouraging."
I am wondering who you like
among these new writers,
can you say something about that?
>> I mean, that quote was
specifically talking about a lot
of the times in South
Africa you meet people
and they will tell you there's
not good literature coming
from South Africa and this is why
I'm reading this or reading that
and I think that's completely
rubbish because I think
if you are really interested
in reading South African
literature you will find it
and you'll find some
really good literature.
Part of the young writers that I
really love reading is [inaudible]
who was short listed for
the Caine Prize with me.
[Inaudible] whose novel [inaudible]
is absolutely amazing [inaudible]
which is an insane novel so
there's a lot of people like that
who are writing at those levels
and I'm hugely excited I think,
to write at this particular
time because I feel
like there's a certain presence of
young Black writers and I'm excited
to be in sort of that space as well.
>> And since we're here in the US,
who are your favorite
American writers?
>> I don't read any American
literature [laughter].
>> Okay, let's go to the
last question [laughter].
>> I mean it's impossible
to escape US literature.
You can try but, so I have
an interesting or I suppose,
I grew up in the villages and
a lot of things that I read
in the villages were
very English I mean,
Shakespeare was one
of the things we read.
So when I started reading, I
was already aware that I needed
to read Black authors so a
lot of authors that I love
from America would be the
Black authors of America,
the Toni Morrison's, Maya
Angelou, so those are the people,
and James Baldwin of course,
so those are the people
that I really love reading
in America and also some
of the newer African-American
writers.
I just call them African writers
so [inaudible] so those are the two
that I really like reading.
>> Okay, my last question and
might be a little bit redundant
but it's one that we always ask,
what do you think is the future
for African writers, both
diasporic and from the continent
and what steps need to be
taken to bring more recognition
from the international community.
So prize wins such as the Caine
Prize of course but what steps need
to be taken to bring
more recognition
from the international community?
>> I mean, it's a very
tricky question to answer
because I think often there's a
disparity between the presence
of African literature and sort
of like what is being published
and what people are reading.
I don't necessarily think
that we as African writers
or African publishers have
to do anything different.
I mean, people are publishing
books, people are publishing online
so for me the thing is if
you are really interested
in reading any African
writer you will find them
and there's a lot going on,
and if you are really
interested you will find them
because they exist everywhere.
>> Okay, well thank you,
thank you very much.
I think we should open
the floor for questions.
>> Thank you, I really enjoyed
hearing part of your story
and I'll finish reading it.
My question to you is you talk about
South Africa, how it's considered
to be possession that causes
mental illness and a lot
of other African cultures it seems
to be continent-wide there seems
to be a denial of mental illness
and therefore a reluctance
to treat it as such.
Do you feel that writing
about it is going to,
you as an African writer writing
about mental illness existing
within the African community will
make it a little bit more accepted
and also lead people to look
at it as an illness rather
than a spiritual possession or
even worse, non-existent at all?
>> I mean, that's I suppose a very
difficult question to answer for me
because I mean, I wrote the story
because I was really concerned
about the conversations
that people were having
around mental illness more so in
my own community in the villages
so the idea was to really bring
that conversation right into sort
of people's everyday life and my
idea was that if I write the story,
people are going to read
it and perhaps we are going
to have this conversation and
I think that's where it begins,
it begins with openly having the
conversation and then we can begin
to kind of change how
society sees it.
The problem is that
no one talks about it.
I mean the story of the
government for example,
that decision was made purely on the
idea that what are you going to do
with mentally ill people?
You can do whatever, because these
people were taken from the hospital
and they were given to [inaudible]
that have no experience at all.
I mean, the horrific stories is
that they were even picked up in,
they were thrown into vans and just
driven out to the villages so part
of my idea with the story was
to do the opposite of that,
was to get people to talk
about it and hopefully once
that conversation begins
we can let it begin to come
up with a number of solutions.
>> Thank you very much.
Your story is very inspiring and you
made me think of different things,
so what are other subjects
that are not talked
about that should be talked about in
literature that you feel as a writer
that should be addressed
and are not being addressed?
And I don't mean necessarily
only in South Africa,
it could be in the United States,
it could be in any other part
of the world that you
feel should be addressed.
>> Oh jeez, I mean I don't know.
I mean, I work on an I suppose
story to story basis and you know,
when I was writing about
mental illness it was something
that I was really thinking
about and when I wrote the film
that I'm continuing to write
because that's something I
was really concerned about,
so I'm not quite sure what else
I could write about in the future
but I certainly know that
one of the interesting things
for me being a village
child is that when you come
to the city there's a
lot of cultural issues,
a lot of cultural indifference
that you sort of have
to reconcile your own beliefs and
kind of the way the city operates
so a lot of my writing is
concerned with that, how do you come
to the city and how much of you
changes and how much of you remains
and what do you become, so
those are some of the things
that I want to write about.
I think part of the one thing I
can tell you about that novel is
that it has a bit of that.
>> As an artist that practices
a lot of different art forms,
how do you make the decision to
put the story that you're thinking
about into writing, versus
film, versus photography?
>> I mean, I don't know
how I make that decision.
I mean, part of it is really
just convenience right?
I have no idea how I would visually
make anything out of mental illness.
I do not see myself taking my
camera and invading people's spaces
like that and making that film but
it felt more comfortable for me
to think about my own community
where I come from in the villages
and write that so a lot
of, I mean it comes to that
and sometimes I mean, I was
in Tanzania before I came here
and there's a big fishing
community in Tanzania
and I made some really
interesting images there
but I didn't write anything about it
so it really depends on what works
at that time and so what
time is available to me
because at the time I was in
Tanzania, I was writing a story
so I didn't have the time to write
another but I could make the images
so it really works in that way.
>> This isn't exactly a question,
I was just going to say that here
in America in Black families,
mentally illnesses are often
really ignored because they're seen
as being in your feelings or you
need to work harder or something
so I don't know, I believe
this may help shape,
this may help like you said,
may help it be more talked
about no like, yes, okay [laughter].
>> I mean, I completely get
you so even in South Africa,
there's a bit of that
especially with depression.
Parents will just tell you go play
outside, listen to some music,
or watch movies as if that helps
so definitely there's a lot more
and this is why I think I mean, the
story has been interesting for me
because a lot of the conversations
about it have been from the point
of the villages and their
traditional living there
but the truth of it is that even
in the city there's a huge problem.
>> You mentioned that you hadn't
written fiction before the short
story and so I was going
to ask what's the most important
thing you've learned in terms
of fiction versus non-fiction?
>> I mean I'm thinking
about it because even
in my non-fiction I make
things up so [laughter] I mean,
I think that the major
difference is really in facts.
There's a certain level
with non-fiction
that you really cannot write
that far away from the truth
but with fiction you
can totally do that.
For me it's all the same because
my poetry exists both in fiction
and non-fiction, the real
difference is really in the facts.
>> A couple of questions, how would
you characterize the relationship
between, or the attitude
of the younger generation
of South African writers to those
that you can maybe call
the older generation
who were writing during
the moment of apartheid?
I think your work on mental
illness, I mean, makes me think
about the work of Bessie
Head for example,
who was engaged more consistently
than perhaps most other South
African writers this particular
issue so I really commend you for,
as a young writer really focusing
on that particular issue there.
The second question I have is in
relation to how, when you write,
how do you position yourself vis a
vis your own indigenous traditions
of narrative?
Do you consciously try to draw
from let's say the oral traditions
to infuse your writing with South
African specificities as far
as style and technique
and so on and so forth?
>> I mean, I think I mentioned this
a little bit that my own encounter
with literature really started very
late in my life and I was already
by then aware of sort of the
presence of I suppose white writers
and I wanted to read more
Black writers so I mean,
Bessie had [inaudible] of course
and a lot of the drama writers
in South Africa were writing at
that time so I've read a lot of that
and I really appreciate
it and I think for me,
in South Africa especially
there seems to have been a space
between the [inaudible] writers
and the writers now after absence
of the Black writer, that
they've been designated to sort
of write certain type of
narratives so I'm really excited
to be writing now in
a space where it feels
like Black writers are
really just concerned
about writing their own story
and not explaining it to anyone
so it's exciting for me
to write at this time.
Not really to the second
question I mean,
one of my favorite writers is
[inaudible] and so my obsession
with writing has always been poetry
and not so much the oral tradition
but it's interesting now
that I think about it
because every time I go to
readings there's a sense
of the oral tradition as well that
exists in that space so I mean,
I'm not a great reader all
but thinking about the way
that we tell stories in
the villages helps a lot
when it comes to the reading for me.
>> Hello, I read your story
yesterday and I was very fascinated.
I don't know whether it's
intentional but I think we all know
that mental illness is a
harsh issue all over Africa,
we don't talk about it and
that this village was engaged,
I was impressed.
I think you typically [inaudible]
to get involved in things.
>> Thank you.
>> I wanted to know what book
are you currently reading?
That's it.
>> I'm currently reading a book
that I picked up in Durban called,
I can't remember the author but it's
called, Fifty Ways to Read a Poem
and it was a column that ran in
The Independent in England I think
and so this person would take a
poem every week and they would write
about that poem and what that poem
is saying, how it's saying it,
the difference between the
narrative and the rhyme of the poem
and I specifically am
reading that because I wanted
to get ready for the novel.
>> Is this an online
source, The Independent,
that you're speaking of now?
>> It was published in The
Independent, which is a paper
in the UK for, someone who
knows The Independent, I think-
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Yes, yes is.
>> Ruth Padel?
>> Yeah, yeah was it
The Independent?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Yeah okay, it's
really an amazing book.
>> Okay I'm just wondering if you
could tell us or make suggestions
on sources that we should
read, that we could read.
You mentioned UK, South
Africa, sometimes it is easy
to get online sources more quickly
than print although we have a
terrific collection of material here
at the Library of Congress
about South Africa as well
as from South Africa, literature,
history, you name it we have it.
Cookery, we have these publications
but make some suggestions
please so that we can remain-
>> I'm going to ask
people to help out,
from the top of my head there's
an online platform called African
in Dialogue from [inaudible], which
is run by a poet called [inaudible]
where she interviews people and
it's really exciting conversations.
There is [inaudible] in Cape
Town which is run by [inaudible],
there is in Nigeria a couple of
them, there's [inaudible] in Kenya,
there's [inaudible] in Kenya,
there's Warscapes, there's Kings
and Kingdoms and what else is there?
There's [inaudible] in Kenya.
>> Brittle paper?
>> Brittle paper.
>> Short Story Day Africa.
>> Yeah, Short Story Day Africa.
Short Shop Stories as
well so there's a couple,
I think it's called [inaudible]
which is based in the UK
for African diasporic
writing so there's also that.
>> Well, thank you, thank you
very much and we're so pleased
that you could come here
and enlighten us, thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.